>>> IT'S "WEEKEND UPDATE" WITH
COLIN JOST AND MICHAEL CHE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> WELCOME TO "WEEKEND UPDATE."
I'M MICHAEL CHE.
>> I'M COLIN JOST.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WELL, WE'RE NOW AT THE POINT
WHERE AT EVERY PRESS CONFERENCE
THE PRESIDENT'S ASKED, WILL
THERE BE A NUCLEAR WAR?
A JOURNALIST ASKED PRESIDENT
BIDEN IF WE SHOULD BE WORRIED
ABOUT NUCLEAR WAR AND HE SAID,
NO.
BECAUSE WHAT'S HE GOING TO SAY?
HELL YEAH, MAN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
START DIGGING A BUNKER, JACK.
IT'S LIKE WHEN A LITTLE KID ASKS
YOU WHERE GRAMPIE'S GOING TO GO
WHEN HE DIES.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE GOING TO SAY
HEAVEN.
BUT BASED ON SOME OF THE STUFF
GRAMPIE SAID YOU KNOW HELL IS
ALSO ON THE TABLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SOME MILITARY EXPERTS HAVE BEEN
SURPRISED THAT DESPITE HAVING
SUPERIOR FIREPOWER THE RUSSIAN
ARMY HAS BEEN SLOWED BY AGING
EQUIPMENT, POOR MOTIVATION AND
INEPT LEADERSHIP.
SO BASICALLY, THEY'RE THE
LAKERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> GERMANY IS NOW JOINING THE
EU TO SEND ARMS TO UKRAINE,
WHICH IS THE FIRST TIME GERMANY
HAS RAMPED UP MILITARY
PRODUCTION SINCE THAT LITTLE
SIX-YEAR GAP IN THEIR HISTORY
BOOKS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> FRENCH PRESIDENT EMMANUEL
MACRON SAID THAT AFTER A TENSE
90-MINUTE CALL WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN, HE'S CONVINCED THAT THE
WORST IS YET TO COME.
MAN, IT'S AMAZING HOW MUCH
SUFFERING COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED IF PUTIN WAS JUST A FEW
INCHES TALLER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM, WHO
GIVES THIS EXACT SAME LOOK AT
THE URINAL --
[ LAUGHTER ]
CREATED CONTROVERSY ON TWITTER
BY SUGGESTING THAT RUSSIANS
SHOULD END THE WAR IN UKRAINE BY
ASSASSINATING VLADIMIR PUTIN.
IT IS A SHOCKING, DISGUSTING
EXAMPLE OF LINDSEY GRAHAM BEING
KIND OF RIGHT ABOUT SOMETHING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> GOVERNORS IN SEVERAL STATES
INCLUDING NEW HAMPSHIRE, OHIO
AND UTAH HAVE BANNED THE SALE OF
RUSSIAN-MADE VODKA.
NO WORD YET ON BRIDES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> MANY OF THE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ATTENDING THE STATE OF
THE UNION WORE BLUE AND YELLOW
TO SHOW THEIR SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINE.
WHILE KAMALA HARRIS WORE ALL
BROWN TO DO WHAT SHE'S DONE FOR
THE LAST YEAR, DISAPPEAR INTO
THE BACKGROUND.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS, SEEN HERE BEING TOLD
SOMEONE'S PRONOUNS --
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DeSANTIS YELLED AT STUDENTS
BEHIND HIM AT AN INDOOR EVENT TO
TAKE OFF THEIR MASKS SAYING
"STOP WITH THIS COVID THEATER."
AND THERE'S NOTHING MORE ON
BRAND FOR CONSERVATIVES THAN A
DAD SCREAMING AT BOYS TO GIVE UP
THEATER.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>>> STARTING ON MONDAY NEW YORK
CITY WILL NO LONGER REQUIRE BARS
AND RESTAURANTS TO PRETEND TO
LOOK AT VACCINATION CARDS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE CITY WILL BE LIFTING ITS
VACCINE MANDATE FOR INDOOR
DINING AND EVENTS.
"FINALLY," SAID THE NEXT
VARIANT.
[ LAUGHTER ]